you
for the most exciting things or two one
is the continued globalization of the
economy and the movement into the global
economy of more and more nations and
more and more people than an enormous
expansion of the real economy in the
world meet by what job by which I mean
that great countries like China and
India large populations have moved into
the global trading economy in the last
few years in a dramatic way and as a
result of that we have rapid economic
growth and improving living standards in
areas of the world that many of us never
expected to see and that's the most
exciting thing going on the second most
exciting thing are the technological
advances which are just enormous and
extremely important and which are I
think in some respects for many of us
are the most exciting thing that's fine
you